vivian what's going on how can i help
how do i stop
negative and hateful feelings i have
towards my body after multiple
miscarriages and
infertility struggles
that one's tough vivian wow thank you
for your trust there
so walk us back through your journey so
far
um so i grew up in a really big family
and my parents
had 10 kids together so i had nine
siblings
um and my mom was just an absolute rock
star she had all of us at home
you're a painkiller she would literally
like sing and she gave birth
she was just incredible did you say she
was singing
yes you know what cuz why not man we're
just gonna take this and pile up on poor
vivian right
aren't golly okay
um she was she was amazing though and
she would talk about
you know the amazing design of a woman's
body and and i always just had a
profound respect for
my own body and um so
kind of fast forwarding um my husband
and i got married and we got pregnant
right away we have a beautiful
four-year-old
and i think unknowingly it just kind of
confirmed because i have a lot of
sisters who've had a lot of kids
kind of not easily but you know just
gotten pregnant quickly and
it just kind of confirmed to me that you
know this will be a breeze and
um and so then um
a while later when we were ready to try
for a second um
i noticed it was taking a long time and
i thought that was weird
and then when i did get pregnant i
miscarried which the first one was just
very jarring i think i was just shocked
that that
happened to me and then we tried again
um after many many months and i became
pregnant again and
um we thought everything was fine that
time and i miscarried almost at the end
of that
um first trimester so i just
i just struggle so much to i feel like
as much of a profound respect
that i used to have for my body i have
an equally profound
disrespect and um frustration
and yeah i'm just not sure how to how
did you
um and again at any point you say hey
i'm done talking about that part um just
cut me off okay
i want you to know your your control of
the conversation here um how did you
grieve
those miscarriages how did you and your
husband do that together
um it's interesting um because i think
i think i've agreed the loss of like
knowing that i'll never know who they
were um you know what they would be like
their hair color all the cried and cried
and just kind of kind of came to a place
of acceptance with that and i think what
i haven't i think
you said it or somebody said that grief
is not just crying a lot it's
ownership and i think i have not owned
that i struggle with fertility
um like one of my close friends said
something to me the other day like
you know how are you doing with your
infertility struggles and i my internal
reaction was like i don't have
infertility struggles like
it's been for years how about you go
drown yourself right yeah
yeah wonderful and she's very well
meaning and hasn't been through it but
sure um but yeah so i i think i have not
grieved that and i think sometimes you
know my husband is wonderful and
very emotionally available um but i
think i just always worry that i'm
bothering him and so i kind of
will just go off and deal with it myself
sometime
when i think he wants to be there for me
so i'm going to answer the best i can
okay having had a ringside seat to this
but not a driver's side seat okay
and um i've talked about some of our
my family's challenges publicly and some
of that stuff i'll keep private
and i'll go to the grave with it and
other stuff um i think it can be helpful
to talk about
and also i'm gonna answer your question
vivian to
a wide audience okay so i'll speak to
you directly but also speak
a broader conversation and let's start
with
you and your husband's conversation so
um when we experience this in my house
with the lion's share of the the pain
resting in my wife
and in her heart um i was working crisis
for the city and so when things went
down in the city i was on a team they
got called out to go help other people
in their worst moments
i was also the dean of students at a
university
and i helped students in their worst
moments and i was working on a second
phd in counseling and a partridge in a
pear tree
long story short if it was going down
chances are they were going to call
delony to come in and help
and then we had a series of challenges
like this in my own home
and i handled it terribly
i had a lot of information i had a lot
of you know what you should be doing
and i missed it completely and i'll
never forget going to a counseling
conference
and i walked into the room and one of
the sessions was counseling women who've
been
had um miscarriages infertility
challenges
and as shameful as this is i was saying
it out loud
um the thought in my head is was
oh i know how to do that because i've
you know i've experienced that i know
how to do that
and then shame on top of shame on top of
shame this is like
an embarrassing moment for me like a
heartbreaking moment for me that i was
just arrogant
but i actually thought i could probably
help in the presentation
so i'll be one of those people in the
audience that helps out the presenter
and during the presentation
the presenter proceeded to say hey we
know we all know this
and she said it so flippantly i'll never
forget it there's like seven things you
never
ever say to a woman who's experienced
this and by the time she got to five and
six
and seven vivian not only had i said all
seven of those things but i had
expounded on him i had
was was like running my mouth about him
in our house
with this with this sense of arrogance
it was one of the most humbling
humiliating shameful moments of my life
because i was just wrong there was one
person on planet earth that i swore
to be there for and it was my wife and i
wasn't
because i was so arrogant and i was just
trying to get there with information and
i wasn't
with and it was when we had some hard
conversations that
that where she really felt um free to
open up that i realized oh my
god almighty i missed it a lot and so
what i would challenge you
before you do anything else is to find
some safe time with your husband
and let him know what's going on in your
heart it will create a division
and a break in your relationship that
will take years to repair
and so um honor him with that and
challenge him with
that but start connecting with him there
okay
and so then here's the back out right
i've heard and again
since that moment it was a humbling
moment you've probably heard me say a
million times on this show and i'll keep
saying it
telling guys to shut their stupid mouths
and to connect with people and don't
over
analyze and don't over inform people a
lot of that
starts from that moment with me right um
so i've heard
these things um throughout time i've
heard
i've been having periods since i was 12
and when it's go time
now you decide to not work i've heard
that i've heard throughout history
women's
women have been recognized and this is
thousands of years right
as a basically a tool for other people
for men to carry on legacy
for um men to have their babies grow to
be fed and on and on
is this this idea that women are always
apologizing for
how their body looks how it works is it
working well is it not working well
and it's exhausting i've heard
women describe how the pain and trying
to
explain to grandparents and in-laws
and their own parents and their husbands
i want to give you grandkids i'm sorry
that we can't do this we had this plan
and it's not working out
i had one buddy of mine tell me about
just walking down that hallway
and looking in that empty room that
there was plans for that empty room
and i've heard heavy heavy things the
most profound
view that has stuck with me that i'll
pass along to you vivian is this idea of
being betrayed by my own body and it
sounds like you're you're familiar with
that one is that one ring true with you
yes very much so like man you were
raised with an
awesome well your mom's not fair number
one that's like
your dad being michael jordan and you
going out for the high school team right
um but you know
this idea that the way it was framed the
way it was told to me and i loved it was
it's like your husband cheated on you
and
you don't get the chance to leave and
there's nothing you
you don't get to talk about working it
out and he doesn't get to change his
behavior because it just
is so you have this betrayal and it
rests
inside of you and there's not a lot you
can do about except going to the next
day and the next day and the next day
does that sound right yes so give us an
example of
when when you have a dark morning a dark
um evening what's the self-talk there
um like if i ask for because i do a lot
my husband works
a lot more than i do i work from home
and part-time
so i take care of a lot of the household
stuff as i feel it should be and
if i ask for anything like any kind of
help with our daughter
sometimes i'll like step in and do it
myself because i'll be like
you know thinking about my sister that
has five kids and like how pathetic that
i would
need help with her one or just things
like that like i'm not allowed to be
tired or you know this age she's four so
lots of questions and sometimes i'm like
i'm just tired you know
and i'll be like wow how are you tired
you have one child that's pathetic
you know and just just anything
yeah just that kind of thing so if you
do
if you get nothing else out of this call
can will you promise me that you'll
start talking to my friend vivian
kinder yes
okay i want you to talk to vivian like
the rock star mom that she is
and you got a beautiful four-year-old
and you have an awesome husband and
you've got a an extraordinary gift for
empathy and for feeling and for
connecting with other people now and
that starts with
you connecting and being empathetic with
yourself okay is that a promise
yes awesome all right so
here's the hard part um you're gonna
have to go through a process of
forgiveness a friend of mine she went as
far as to name her uterus and of course
she named it after a man because why not
but she literally went through a process
of forgiveness
named it and got a group of people
around her
that she could talk with but had to go
through the process of forgiving her own
body
and that sounds weird and that sounds
awkward whether that's writing in a
letter whether that
is or writing your yourself your body a
letter
but the idea of not forgiving this is
you are poisoning yourself from the
inside out and you are wearing this
chemical response you're wearing this
frustrating frustration response
and it just gets heavy and eventually
your body goes to war with you
right and so you've got to be about
forgiving your body for
not living up to what you think it
should have to the expectations you put
on it to the quote unquote beautiful
machinery that you were given right then
the second thing is
this is hard but there's always going to
be an ache there
and it's as time goes on as you grieve
it
you're gonna make peace with that ache
and then you're gonna learn
and give in to celebrating others right
it's hard when your sorority sister
texts everybody and says guess what
guess what right or they send that cute
little instagram thing
that still sucks doesn't it yeah yeah
yeah it's some as you're gonna have to
lean
into those moments and practice
gratitude and practice celebrating other
people as hard and ugly as that will be
and then i really want you to explore
the story of motherhood in your heart
and in your home and with your husband
and you've traced it you've done an
awesome job of tracing all the way back
to the
the example that your extraordinary mom
set and the way she
talked about how beautiful your body was
um
and this extraordinary appreciation for
how your body works
you're gonna have to get beneath that
and ask yourself questions about do you
want to be a mom
do you wanna have five kids running
around does that mean you're gonna go
through the adoption process does that
mean you are going to
you really just want to be a mom if
you're biological kid so you're gonna be
a mom and the best aunt that's ever been
you're gonna foster
you need to have those type of
conversations as you begin to make
meaning of
well then what is going to be next and
those are not things you need to do by
yourself
okay you got to have a community around
you please please please please
involve your husband in those
conversations and then the last
hard hard part of this is you have to
decide if you're going to be vulnerable
again
and nobody in the entire world can make
that decision except for you
and are you going to exhale
and then go again or are you going to
um say i'm done with the hurt and we are
blessed with the child that we've got
and then we're going to start exploring
what family means for us down the road
um i'm confident you've already had
those thoughts
where are you leaning on the
vulnerability
um do you mean like as far as trying
again or like talking with my husband
um i do think we we want to in the
future
um i think some of this is probably
coming up too because we
were not trying um currently because we
have a move
possibly coming up and um i just feel
like my daughter's getting older and
there's not a sibling
and so that's been kind of sad but
um i do think we do want to try in the
future
but just maybe not right now awesome and
you're telling yourself a lot of stories
about how your kids are feeling and how
your
daughter's absorbing this and how your
husband's gonna respond
don't get in the head of other people
and begin trying to solve problems for
them that they haven't
communicated to you okay you've got
enough to carry and it's hard
and yours your heart and soul is so good
that you are s
you want to care for everybody around
you and in the process
you're going to end up drowning yourself
you're gonna end up bringing drop
carrying so much weight that um
it brings you down and those stories
that you're telling about your daughter
man your daughter's gonna be awesome
whether she has
a biological sibling 10 biological
siblings or if it's just the three of
y'all then you all ride or die together
she's got an awesome mom and a great dad
she's going to be a great cousin you're
going to be a great hand all of those
things work together
but it starts with you having a moment
or a
season of forgiveness for the body
that's betrayed you
and then it begins a reframing for
what's this body gonna
gonna how's this body gonna support
moving forward and then what's family
going to look like in our home
vivian it sucks i hate that this is
happening to you and
i know that there are millions and
millions of women in the country who are
experiencing and all over the world
experiencing exactly what you're going
through
and there's millions of husbands sitting
next to wives just like this
going i'm hurting too and i don't know
how to hurt i don't know what to say i
don't know how to say it
and so start there with your husband
have that conversation
and then y'all can lean into the
forgiveness process and let me know how
those conversations go and we will be
thinking about you